what do you think is the role of love
in the human condition
why is it useful is it useful like uh
hack or is this like fundamental to what
it means to be human the capacity to
love
i mean i think love is the evolutionary
mechanism that is like beginning the
intelligent design like i was just
reading
about uh
do you know what crow pot kropotkin he's
like an anarchist like old russian
anarchist i live next door to uh michael
malus i don't know if you know that is
he's an anarchist he's a modern day
anarchist okay anarchists are fun i'm
kind of getting into anarchism a little
bit this is probably
yeah not a good route to be taking but
oh no i i think if you're listen you
should expose yourself to ideas there's
no harm to thinking about ideas i think
anarchists
challenge systems in interesting ways
and they think in interesting ways it's
just it's good for the soul it's like
refreshes your mental palate i don't
think we should actually
i i wouldn't actually ascribe to it but
i i've never actually gone deep on on
anarchy as a philosophy so i'm you still
think about it like when you when you
listen because i'm like reading about
the russian revolution a lot and was
like there was like the soviets and
lenin all that but then there was like
krapotkin and his like anarchist sect
and they were sort of interesting
because he was kind of a technocrat
actually like he was like you know like
women can be more equal if we have
appliances like he was like really into
like um you know
using technology to like reduce the
amount of work people had to do
but so kropaken was a
like a biologist or something like he
studied animals um and he was re really
at the time
like uh i think it's nature
magazine
i think he might have even started like
a russian magazine but he was like
publishing studies like everyone was
really into like darwinism at the time
and like survival of the fittest and
like war is like the mechanism by which
we become better and it was like this
real
kind of like
like pro like
cementing this idea in society that like
violence uh
you know kill the weak and like that's
how we become better and then kropotkin
was kind of interesting because he was
looking at um instances he was finding
all these instances in nature where
animals were like helping each other and
stuff and he was like you know actually
love is a survival mechanism like
there's
so many uh
instances in the animal kingdom where
like cooperation
and you know like helping weaker
creatures and all this stuff is actually
um an evolutionary mechanism i mean you
even look at child rearing like child
rearing is
like
immense amounts of just love and good
will and just like there's no immediate
um
you're there you know you're not getting
any immediate feedback of like
winning it's not competitive it's
literally it's you know it's like we
actually use love as an evolutionary
mechanism just as much as we use war and
i i think we've like missing the other
part and we've reoriented we've
culturally reoriented like science and
philosophy has re has
oriented itself around darwinism a
little bit too much and the krapotkin
model um i think is equally valid like
it's like cooperation and um
uh
and love and stuff is just as essential
for
uh
species survival and evolution to be a
more powerful survival mechanism
in the context of evolution and it comes
back to like you know we think
engineering is so much more important
than motherhood but it's like
if you lose the motherhood that
engineering means nothing we have no
more humans like it's like uh uh you
know it's like we
i i think our society should
the survival of the the way we see we
conceptualize evolution should really
change to also include this idea i guess
yeah there there's some weird thing that
seems irrational
that it seem
is also core to what it means to be
human so
uh love is one such thing it could make
you do a lot of irrational things but
that depth of connection and that
loyalty is a powerful thing are they
irrational or are they rational like
it's like it's like is uh
you know
maybe
losing out on some things in order to
like keep your family together or in
order like it's like
what are our actual values like well
right i mean the rational thing is
if you have a cold economist perspective
you know motherhood or sacrificing your
career for love
you know if you turn in terms of salary
in terms of economic well-being in terms
of flourishing of you as a human being
that could be seen
on some kind of metrics as a irrational
decision or suboptimal decision but
there is the
manifestation of love
could could be the optimal thing to do
there's a kind of saying
save one life save the world
there's a thing that doctors often face
which is like well it's considered
irrational because the profit model
doesn't include social good yes yeah so
food is social good then suddenly these
would be rational decisions this might
be difficult to
you know it requires a shift in our
thinking about profit
and might be difficult to measure
social good yes
but we're learning to measure a lot of
things like we're digitizing we're
actually you know quantifying
vision
and stuff like we're like we're like
you know like you you go on facebook and
they can like facebook can pretty much
predict our behaviors like we we're
a surprising amount of things that seem
like
uh mysterious consciousness
soul things have been quantified at this
point so surely we can quantify these
other things
you